deux hôtes de marque aujourd'hui au
centre d'essais en vol de brétigny dans
l'essonne le rafale c'est à dire le
futur avion de combat tactique conçu par
dassault et la snecma le rafale donc et
le secrétaire d'état américain à la
défense
venue assister à ces essais en vol le
rafale c'est donc à l'enjeu stratégique
est mais c'est aussi pour notre région
un enjeu industriel
le reportage de jean pierson premier vol
lui et 86 première grande démonstration
quelques semaines plus tard à
farnborough aujourd'hui à brétigny
rafale en était à son 79e vol et les
résultats obtenus s'avère hyper
satisfaisant décollage foudroyant
vitesse ascensionnelle époustouflante
maniabilité incroyable en regardant cet
essai en vol du rafale
nous étions tous électrisés
l'atterrissage en beauté sur 300 mètres
comme petit avion de ligne
un peu plus tard dans le hangar du
rafale le secrétaire américain à la
défense se refusait à toute déclaration
mais son intérêt paris ce ministre est
habilité à nice pour deux sous qu'est ce
que cela représente
c'est l'avenir ces industries
aéronautique et au point attaché au
lancement de cet avion pour ça que cette
palabre en tant qu ils soient lancés
rapidement parce qu'aujourd'hui la pas
de concurrent des sous c'est 30% du
rafale
à ses côtés la snecma et toute
l'industrie des matériaux composites un
atout considérable pour l'économie d'île
de france